I can show you the world finally the
most recognizable voice in America sings
the greatest duets of all time with the
most recognizable voice in America a
whole new world a new fantastic
[Music]
and Ray Romano present Romano duets you
say potato I say potato you say tomato I
say tomato potato potato tomato tomato
let's call the whole thing
[Music]
and the duets just keep coming
islands in the stream that is what we
are no one in between how can we be
wrong
[Music]
yeah yeah you a little off it was good
though Thanks romance and your
[Music]
they tell me how much you care
from London what can you will find me
time after time if you fall I will catch
you time after time yes the greatest
duets of all time on six compact discs
and if you order now will include free
of charge
Romano quartets order today the Romano
parody seven years ago so this was a
dream come true to do it with the actual
Ray Romano I it's too amazing when we
were doing it we were shooting Romano
sings and we were gonna shoot Romano do
what's right after it and our times
overlapped so I'm singing and then I
hear I've never met him before in my
life
I don't know he walked in he comes in
the shadows and I just hear what the
hell is that
[Music]